tragedy strikes again on the west coast
just hours after a man opened fire
inside of a dance studio in Southern
California authorities in Northern
California were dealing with their own
mass shooting on Saturday night police
say a man in his 70s targeted people at
a ballroom dance club celebrating the
Lunar New Year and 11 people died
several hundred miles up the coast
another man aimed his weapon at
co-workers on two mushroom farms in Half
Moon Bay allegedly killing seven
deputies took down 66-year-old Zao Chun
Li after spotting him in a car in the
parking lot of a sheriff's substation
authorities say Chun Li worked at the
mountain mushroom farm in Half Moon Bay
Chun Li is believed to have shot eight
people in total between that location
and another farm and only one person
survived is actually out of surgery
right now all evidence points to
workplace violence as the cause for the
shooting the San Mateo County Sheriff
says that the shooting happened in the
afternoon when children were out of
school so they actually ended up
witnessing the violence some of the
victims were Hispanic While others were
of Asian descent police say they're
struggling to make next of kin
notifications because of language
barriers and migrant status
meantime a vigil was held in Monterey
Park to remember the 11 victims of the
Lunar New Year's shooting Witnesses say
the suspect who took his own life as
police moved in to arrest him had been a
frequent visitor of Star Dance Studio in
the past authorities believe who Tran
was targeting specific people but his
exact motives are not yet known while he
had been known to socialize with people
at a dance clubs and even volunteers and
instructor residents do say that he was
known to hold grudges Tran had recently
visited a police station where he lived
in Hemet claiming that family members
were trying to poison him and steal his
money he actually came to report the
claim twice and police told him that he
needed actual evidence after a day-long
Manhunt in the Monterey Park area police
found trans white fan and heard one
gunshot as they approached finding Tran
Dead Inside So Terry the authorities are
still determining the motivation behind
these shootings but there has been
speculation these you know hate crimes
when we talk about that what is a hate
crime so actually it's on the federal
and state level it's a crime that's
motivated invaded by hate or bias
against a particular group of people and
it's usually based on race or color or
national origin or gender or gender
identity and you know if you are charged
and prosecuted with a hate crime the
penalties are going to be much greater
now Most states do have hate crimes
California definitely does South
Carolina and Wyoming are the only two
that don't and I think this could if you
know they look into it it finds out
motivation it could have been classified
as a hate crime talking about motivation
Brian how important is it for the police
to announce what the motive was and the
halfway halfway Moon shooting well Jesse
in this shooting as well as the other
shooting you were talking about there
was a suspicion as Terry was alluding to
that this could be a hate crime remember
the Idaho case when people are waiting
for them to announce what was going on
whether or not the community was safe
imagine that but for our Asian brother
and sisters or those of Asian descent
they were probably on edge thinking is
this someone who is targeting us how do
we stay safe what do we we know I think
informing the public especially of the
half moon shooting that this appears to
be work related and not race related
helps to ease tensions and helps that
relationship between the police and its
citizens all right